today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
lives
[Music]
to help treat patients battling a
current infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
[Music]
virus
[Music]
[Music]
convalescent
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman he
is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman their
emotional they are
mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's a lot of agree with everything
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman he is a baby
david patman he is a baby
he gave it pacman he is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're acting
like a because you're asking bizarre
questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right thank you for coming
[Music]
that's a progressive vote all men
who are progressive are we
all right welcome everybody i know that
that song always gets people very very
fired up uh we have something different
today we are going to have complete
sentences today
we are going to have coherent thoughts
today we are going to have something we
recognize
as the english language today uh we are
going to have
hypothetical and and and metaphorical
speech
today uh because we are going to hear
from barack obama
barack obama has been doing a full day
of campaigning for joe biden in
pennsylvania
scheduled sometime between 10 and 25
minutes from now it's not clear to me
whether it's scheduled for quarter of or
or the top of the hour um we are going
to be hearing from uh former president
barack obama in philadelphia
we then are going to be hearing i guess
from donald trump in gastonia north
carolina
and i'm going to be really upfront so
we're going to do the obama stuff
and then we'll do like a pre-trump rally
thing and then i may be gone i
i i mean at this point we're
increasingly not really needing
what i'm trump says the same thing at
every single one of these it's sort of
like how orange is he
is it upper or down or trump is he mango
tangerine
amber you know what's the color uh uh
and and sort of like how how deranged is
he how late is he
um who goes with him yesterday melania
was supposed to go but he's saying the
same thing at every single one of these
so
since we're starting earlier today with
the obama stuff we pr they're doing a
pre-show right now in gastonia
i probably won't cover much if at all of
the actual trump rally particularly if
he's very very late but we have
plenty of time plenty plenty plenty of
time
to discuss different things but for now
we are standing by with multiple streams
that i'm monitoring for you
for the former president barack obama
we'll stick with this one first
this one says they're starting in eight
minutes so we will be
here and we are going to follow it all
extremely closely so listen if you've
been following the news at all today
i'm going to tell you a story about rudy
giuliani
basically through my tweets so the first
tweet about this
was four hours ago where i tweeted
oh boy just heard about the rudy
giuliani situation in borat 2 is their
video floating around now at this point
i had heard
that it seems as though rudy giuliani
made
a i don't even know what to call it
he thought he was i guess going to be
hooking up with a woman that
maybe he thought was 15 but it's an
actress who's 24
and at one point he had his hand in his
pants and it was pretty wild
so that was four hours ago then i
learned more about what was going on
and i saw this article and i posted it's
going to be a really special week for
rudy giuliani
rudy julia whoa hold on a second let me
get a better zoom
rudy giuliani faces new faces questions
after compromising scene in new borat
film
trump's personal attorney has indiscrete
encounter with actor
playing borat's daughter in hotel room
during pandemic
and this is so funny this article
contains spoilers
about borat subsequent movie film
i mean how is this how is this the the
real world right now you know
uh the reputation of rudy giuliani could
be set for a further blow if you can
imagine it being even more in the toilet
with the release of highly embarrassing
footage and sasha baron cohen's
follow-up to borat
in the film released on friday meaning
it's going to be released this coming
friday
uh the former new york mayor and current
personal attorney to donald trump
is seen reaching into his trousers
and apparently touching his genitals
while reclining out of bed in the
presence of the actor playing borat's
daughter
who's posing as a tv journalist i guess
the the the gist of it was
they said that this actress was a
right-wing journalist who wanted to
interview rudy
following an obsequious interview for a
fake conservative news program
the pair retreat at his at her
suggestion for a drink to the bedroom of
a hotel suite
which is rigged with concealed cameras
after she removes the mic
giuliani 76 can be seen lying on his
back
on the bed fiddling with his untucked
shirt and reaching into his trousers
they are then interrupted by borat who
runs in and says she's 15
she's too old for you um
it's all just completely unbelievable
and this really may be the end of rudy
giuliani
uh then i posted rudy giuliani right now
sweating
sweating sweating sweating um
okay i'll get back to that story in a
second and then this picture was
released
it's all just crazy this picture was
released
and then the drudge had line of point
was this this is drudge report i mean
it's
it it's just unbelievable now to add
like one more layer to the insanity
people who have seen the film already
report
that root this was during during
coronavirus during corvid
as some people are referring to it and i
guess rudy was coughing throughout the
entire thing as well like you could
even the the most minute details are
just
stunning like on top of whatever
rudy is doing here um he was coughing
throughout the
the entire thing so it's it's really
incredible
and then you know more pictures here
this is i guess rudy holding hands with
with the actress and he seems almost to
be in
maybe the middle of some kind of
gregorian chant or something like that
uh here is where i now this one looks
weird but i guess this is just the
actress
who rudy thinks is a journalist not an
actress
is um removing his microphone
and then this this is when rudy's left
hand seems to be well
well in his fans like how how do you
explain this as
any it's it's just unbelievable what is
going on here
and then of course a lot of people uh
taking pleasure in
they are interrupted by borat who runs
in and says she's 15 she's too old for
you now i do want to say something that
i think is relevant
here uh for me you know there's this
thing about oh
are we are we instituting our view of
morality
like if rudy has an open relationship
with his wife
and everything's consensual then
whatever right
for me there's a bigger story which is
that rudy giuliani is just such a doofus
that
you know he rudy said it's 50 50.
it's 50 50 that i worked with a
uh with a russian spy on the hunter
biden story
uh rudy is so easily bamboozlable if
that's a word and if it's not
you know okay then i think you all
understand what i'm saying
that he's just such a dunce like how do
you you
how do you end up in this position you
know literally and metaphorically
um that's really the story you know if
rudy and his wife have an open
relationship
great but it's just the lack of judgment
and the falling for this it's just
incredible it's just
incredible and this may be the end of
rudy giuliani's career we i i don't
believe that there
there has been comment so far um
but um from rudy or from from the trump
administration
but it is just absolutely insane
insane insane moments um
and some people are saying it's not
really 50 50 that he worked with a
russian spy on the hunter story
but by the way i also posted earlier
today and i got a bunch of interesting
responses to this where was this this
morning
uh yeah wait so the computer repair shop
owner to whom hunter biden supposedly
dropped off the laptop
is legally blind that i hear that
correctly i guess the guy who supposedly
is the source that said this was hunter
biden
i guess we've since learned the guy is
blind and that's who
say so hunter biden was was identified
on i mean
it's it's just every detail with these
people
is completely completely absurd
um i i just don't even know and i know
people are saying well how does how do
you do computer repair if you're blind
i i don't think that that's really and
disability shaming
how did he know it was hunter biden uh
if if he's blind that's the entire
that's the entire point here guys and i
understand legally blind doesn't mean
fully blind i
i get it okay but it's just all of the
details the entire story is hinging on a
guy
i you know who knows how many miles from
where hunter biden supposedly lives
who does really unusual things with hard
drives i mean it's just it's
all bizarre it's all completely bizarre
okay um let me do
a few oh rudy's not oh rudy's divorce i
didn't know that
okay if rudy is single i did not realize
that
then uh then then take that back a
couple of um
a couple of memes for you guys this is
called
jessie we peterson this is originally me
holding a friend's baby
and somebody photoshopped in jesse lee
peterson's face
and this is now jesse we peterson
i think that this is pretty good i think
that's good
um and then one other one
jesse lee ben carson peterson the ii
there's me wearing my data mail shirt
and cheersing i guess
while jesse wears a beta male shirt
and okay i mean that's not bad i do
think this one is better
i think this one is better but this
really isn't bad
so a couple updates as far as memes
are concerned we are now standing by
for barack obama scheduled for some time
in the next 15 minutes the party has
already started as you can see
with diamond and silk on state let's
just listen to a few seconds of it
on earth
[Applause]
right here right here yes
[Applause]
come on i don't know guys they're pretty
convincing
[Applause]
so if you want to remain the greatest
country
on earth you're going to have to vote
for president
donald j trump
she sounds way less unhinged than
kimberly guilfoyle i have to tell you
this
after if you watch kimberly guilfoyle
and then you come to this this sounds
normal
uh and as you can see someone with a
blacks for trump shirt
in a position where i i imagine they
will be right over trump's left shoulder
uh which is which is the ideal spot for
propagandistic placement of minorities
during trump events so everything
happening
in gastonia north carolina but right now
we are waiting for barack obama
and we will we will keep an eye on that
okay guys let me get to some super chats
before
i do that just a few thank yous david
chadman has just
resubscribed very strongly society is
broken has subscribed on twitch
amber gifford has subscribed petul and
stephen is a new subscriber
and a hype train is out of the station
thanks to five gifted subs from boy
meets mini
as far as the website is concerned k
standifer is new member number one
shane ryan is number two amber gifford
doubling up is number three i appreciate
that
three subscribers on joinpakman.com
let's get into super chats i want to
hear from you guys and see what you guys
think let's go to the top
okay marianne zimmerman says david if
you want to talk to a far-left
non-accelerationist call a danish social
democrat
okay that's an idea jr says hey david
thanks for playing my song yesterday it
meant a lot i'm gonna make a full band
version soon
other than that get out and vote yeah we
had like a folk song submitted yesterday
which was really good
uh what else do we have here daniel
krieger says payday for me equals payday
for you
matt says sasha baron cohen pulled the
chris hanson on rudy giuliani
yeah i mean it's just when you look at
this picture hold on a second
th this is just i don't think drudge
has ever had anything even approximating
this it's just incredible it's
it's almost beyond belief it's almost
beyond belief
stunning stunning but you can't look
away you really can't
uh tr or talar says did you see that
giuliani allegedly turned over
evidence of cp from hunter's laptop to
delaware state police child porn
how will this impact the election if at
all if it's not true then is damage
already done i don't think anybody's
talking about it
for now for now wade flores says david
my betta fish jesse lee betta fish says
you are amazing he legit gets excited
when i stream you on the big screen
you have a fish that likes the streams
that's interesting
chuck says david please slap beta male
bro
borat 2032 okay alexander says just
finished today's show
love the deep dive into systemic racism
yeah we had a 23-minute video on
systemic racism
that was included in today's podcast and
it'll be on youtube
soon soon amy says should i wear a mask
to watch
trump's rally last time the crowd was so
packed i was worried i might catch
coveted through the screen
you know it's funny you mentioned that i
actually got a um
let me see if i can find it hold on uh
the other day i got a voicemail from
this guy
troy york who just leaves voicemail he's
desperate to be on the show
and i didn't we haven't had him on the
show but he left me this voicemail this
is on my
instagram where he was asking why i
don't wear a mask while i stream take a
listen
little argentine israeli troll and
why aren't you wearing a mask you do
this live stream all your shows i never
see you
you wear a [ __ ] mask uh uh
when you're doing your live streams you
know so right why are you wearing
goggles why
why don't you have headphones on and and
a necklace when
all that money you make you don't have
an old gold necklace
how come you don't have a gold tooth
like uh [ __ ]
[Music]
uh flavored flavor right you know yeah
yeah why don't i wear a mask by myself
in the room okay um
we have new tweets i'm being told from
rudy giuliani let's see if he's reacting
okay oh my god here we go the borat
video oh my god he's going with this
the borat video is a complete
fabrication
i was tucking in my shirt after taking
off the recording equipment okay
is this how you tuck in your shirt is
that how you guys tuck in your shirt
that's weird that's a weird explanation
this is what we call doubling down
at no time before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate well
inappropriate could just be a a you know
alluding to consent and nobody's
uh alleging that it was not consensual
so this is a non-denial it's i mean it's
it's a stupid denial
if sasha baron cohen implies otherwise
he is a stone cold liar
in fact the new york post today reports
it looks to me like an exaggeration
through editing
as soon as i realized it was a setup i
called the police which has been noticed
in thr
article on july 8th this is an effort to
blunt
my rel interesting use of the word to
blunt my relentless exposure of the
criminality and depravity of joe biden
and his entire family deadline hollywood
reports caa had a distribution screening
in september
where there was no mention of the scene
holding any importance we are preparing
much bigger dumps
off of the hard drive from hell off
which joe biden
will be unable to hide or defend from i
have the receipts oh my god
that is unbelievable um wow
so i have to retweet this uh
rudy is fully doubling down
insisting he was merely tucking in his
shirt
the next 48 hours
should be absolutely
off the wall that is an unbelievable
explanation it really is
oh okay good we are getting close to the
barack obama event this is great we're
going to have
as i said earlier we're going to have
coherent thought ideas
complete sentences uh prepositional
phrases you know that that sort of thing
so i'm really glad that you guys are
here and then later we will get to some
of the donald
trump rally which is coming up later i
don't know what this is
but we've got a we've got our eyes
trained on
all of these different elements and i
think it's a really really great thing
robert white is new member number four
at joinpackman.com and
denny west is new member number five
today i really appreciate the support
from everybody during during the streams
other super chats coming in
i i did get distracted maddie isis david
is that scott zolac on the trump stream
i have no i don't know who that is i'm
not sure
babe ruthless says melania is the only
first lady in modern history not to set
foot on the campaign trail ahead of the
election what's the
likelihood melania files for divorce
when trump loses next month i wouldn't
be shocked yeah
i mean now she has coveted and that's
apparently why she wasn't at last
night's rally
but she wasn't at any of the pre uh you
know the previous rallies either so who
knows
anthony correcting me that rudy got
divorced last year uh i appreciate that
correction
um ali reza says well-placed rudy's hand
will be on bible for truth
it's just wild that's what rudy should
go rudy should actually go
i actually like that rudy should go with
i had a bible in my pants
which i was swearing on in fact i think
i'm going i'm going to tweet that
um hold on let me go i'm gonna just do
another one of these
rudy would be better off going with i
had a
bible in my pants which i was swearing
on at the time of the screen cap
there we go my god
what a day what a day can you imagine
all right let's go to barack obama here
actually i should be careful with the
music
we'll just give it a moment but we are
going to hear from barack obama here we
go
hello philadelphia
it is good to be back in pennsylvania
what beautiful weather we got here a
little indian summer
you know i know uh the president spent
some time in erie last night and uh
apparently he complained about having to
travel here
the event short yes i don't feel that
way
i love coming to pennsylvania
you guys delivered for me twice and i am
back here tonight to ask you to deliver
the white house for joe biden and kamala
harris
[Music]
it's a drive-in that's why there's horns
just so you guys know
i want to thank mr philadelphia charlie
mack
his daughter india marie what an
outstanding young lady she was
those of you who are fathers and have
daughters you know how that feels when
when you see your daughters just
shining i know a little bit about that
and it was great to see representatives
brendan boyle
mary gay scanlon governor tom wolf
attorney general josh shapiro mayor jim
kenney
philadelphia we got 13 days
that's our lucky number right here 13
days
until the most important election of our
lifetimes
and you don't have to you don't have to
wait
for november 3rd to cast your ballot
you've got two ways to vote right now
number one you can vote early in person
through next tuesday
good comment i like that anybody here
voted
early already
[Music]
just if you haven't just go to
iwillvote.com
pa and find out where you can vote early
number two you can vote from home with a
mail-in ballot
just go to iwillvote.com pa
to request your ballot right away and
before you send it back
pennsylvania's got this thing where
you've got to use both envelopes
so you've got to read the directions
carefully to make sure your vote counts
it's going to be tough for some people
and if you've already voted
then you've got to help your friends and
family make a plan to vote
take them with you if you vote early
or if you vote in person on election day
because
this election requires every single one
of us to do our part
and what we do these next 13 days
will matter for decades to come that's
for sure
now last time i was in philadelphia i
was at
the constitution center
and i was delivering a speech for the
democratic national convention this year
and i said during that speech i've sat
in the oval office with both of the men
who are running for president and they
are very different people
i explained that i never thought donald
trump
would embrace my vision or continue my
policies
but i did hope for the sake of the
country
that he might show some interest in
taking the job seriously
you were wrong but it hasn't happened
he hasn't shown any interest in doing
the work
or helping anybody but himself and his
friends
or treating the presidency like a
reality show
that he can use to get attention
and by the way even then his tv ratings
are down
so you know that upsets him that's
pretty funny
[Music]
but the thing is this is not a reality
show this is reality
and the rest of us have had to live with
the consequences
of him proving himself incapable of
taking
the job seriously
at least 220 000 americans
have died more than 100
000 small businesses have closed
not
if the country is available off than it
was four years ago
i'll tell you one thing four years ago
you'd be tailgating here at the link
instead of watching a speech from your
cars the only people
truly better off than they were four
years ago
are the billionaires who got his tax
cuts
right now as we speak trump won't even
extend relief to the millions of
families who are having trouble paying
the rent
or putting food on the table because of
this pandemic guys this is too coherent
he's been doing all right by himself
as it turns out this was just reported
in the last 48
hours we know that he continues to do
business with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i
had a secret chinese bank account when i
was running for reelection
you think you think you think fox news
might have been a little concerned about
that
they would have called me beijing berry
that's not bad it is not
a great idea to have a president
who owes a bunch of money to people
overseas
that's that's not a good idea i mean of
the taxes donald trump pays
he may be sending more to foreign
governments than he pays
in the united states for sure first year
in the white house he only paid 750
in federal income tax listen my first
job was at a baskin-robbins
when i was 15 years old
i think i might have paid more taxes
that year working at a
dispensing ice cream
how is that possible how many
people here paid less than that
it's possible just possible now that if
if you are living high on the hog and
you only pay 750
dollars in taxes that maybe just maybe
he might not know what working people
are going through here in pennsylvania
cannot afford four more years of this
philadelphia
but the good news is right now you can
choose change
right now you can vote for my friend joe
biden
and his running mate kamala harris as
the next president
and vice president of the united states
of america
[Music]
now joe joe's no stranger to hear he
he's a native son
scrappy kid from scranton you know him
and you know he knows you but let me
let me tell you how i came to know him
and and how i came to love him
12 years ago when i chose
when i chose joe biden as vice president
as
as my vice presidential running main
i didn't know joe all that well we had
served in the senate together but we
weren't
super close he and i came from different
places
we came from different generations
but i came to admire joe
as a man who has learned early on
to treat everybody he meets with dignity
and respect
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe but
you're better than nobody
and that empathy there's an idea that
decency
that belief that everybody counts that's
who joe is
that's who he'll be and i can tell you
the presidency
doesn't change who you are it reveals
who you are
and joe has shown himself to be a friend
of working people
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room when i faced a big decision
he made me a better president and he's
got the character and experience to make
us
a better country and he and kamala
are going to be in the fight not for
themselves
but for every single one of us
look i get that this president wants
full credit for the economy he inherited
and zero blame for the pandemic that he
ignored
but you know what the job doesn't work
that way
tweeting at the television doesn't fix
things we'll see if he gets reelected
stuff up doesn't make people's lives
better
you've got to have a plan you've got to
put in the work
and along with the experience to get
things done joe biden has concrete plans
and policies
that will turn our vision of a better
fairer stronger country
into a reality
we literally left this white house a
pandemic playbook
threw it out that would have shown them
how to respond
before the virus reached our shores
they probably used it to i don't know
prop up a wobbly table somewhere we
don't know where that playbook went
eight months into this pandemic cases
are rising
again across this country
donald trump isn't suddenly going to
protect all of us
he can't even take the basic steps to
protect himself
[Music]
just last night he complained up in erie
that the pandemic made him go back to
work i'm quoting here
he was he was upset that the pandemics
made him go back to work
he didn't want to go to erie but he had
to working the whole time it never would
have gotten this bad
so look here's the truth i want to be
honest here
this pandemic would have been
challenging for any president correct
but this idea that somehow this white
house
has done anything but completely screw
this up
is just not true i'll give you a very
specific example korea identified its
first case
at the same time that the united states
did yeah but they're authoritarian man
at the same time not true by the way
their per capita death toll is just 1.3
of what ours is in canada it's just
39 of what ours is other countries
are still struggling with the pandemic
but they're not doing as bad as we are
because they've got a government that's
actually been paying attention
and that means lives lost and that means
an economy that doesn't work
and just yesterday by the way people who
think south korea really is more
authoritarian than us
they rank higher on the democracy index
than the u.s
not much nothing you can think of that
could have
helped some people keep their loved ones
alive
so joe's not going to screw up testing
he's not going to call scientists
idiots he's not going to host a super
spreader event
at the white house
joe will get this pandemic under control
with a plan to make testing free and
widely available
to get a vaccine to every american
cost-free
and to make sure our front-line heroes
never ask other countries for the
equipment they need
his plan will guarantee paid sick leave
for workers and parents
affected by the pandemic and make sure
that the small businesses that hold our
communities together
and employ millions of americans can
reopen safely
you know donald donald trump likes to
claim he built this economy
but america created 1.5 million more
jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in the first three years of the
trump pence administration i've pointed
that out before
that and that was before he could blame
the pandemic
now he did inherit the longest streak of
job growth in american history
but just like everything else he
inherited he messed it up
the economic damage he inflicted by
botching the pandemic response means he
will be the first president
since herbert hoover to actually lose
jobs
joe's got a plan to create 10 million
hey at least trump's paving the way on
something
as part of a historic two trillion
dollar investment
to fight climate change to secure
environmental justice
and he'll pay he'll pay for it by
rolling back that tax cut for
billionaires
and joe sees this moment not just as a
chance to get back to where we were
but to finally make long overdue changes
so that our economy actually makes life
a little easier for everybody the
waitress trying to raise her kid on her
own
the student trying to figure out how to
pay for next semester's classes
the shift worker who's always on the
edge of getting laid off
the cancer survivor who's worried about
her pre-existing conditions protections
being taken away let me tell you
something pennsylvania
this i know to be true joe and kamala
will protect your health care
and expand medicare and make insurance
more affordable
for everybody
[Applause]
you know republicans love to say
right before an election that they'll
protect your pre-existing conditions
now joe and i actually protected your
policies to make sure people with
pre-existing conditions could get health
insurance and have coverage
we did it through something called the
affordable care act
aka obamacare
and republicans try to repeal
or undermine it more than 60 times
and when they've been asked about they
they keep on promising we're going to
have a great replacement
they said it's coming it's been coming
in two weeks for the last 10 years
that's good where is it where is this
great plan to replace obamacare
it's gone we've had 10 years to do it
there is no plan
they've never had one there was one that
would kick 30 million people off
affordable care act at every turn
driving up costs driving up the
uninsured now they're trying to
dismantle your care in the supreme court
as we speak as quickly as they can in
the middle of a pandemic
with nothing but empty promises this is
a drive-in rally if people are just
joining us yeah
it's shameful the idea that you would
take
health care away from people at the very
moment where people need
it most what is the logic of that
there is no logic
joe knows that a first the first job of
a president
is to keep us safe from all threats
foreign
when the daily intelligence briefings
flash warning signs about a virus
a president can't ignore him he can't be
awol yeah you go golf
just like when russia puts bounties on
the heads of our soldiers in afghanistan
the commander-in-chief can't be missing
in action
you got to go golf i i can tell you this
joe biden would never call the men and
women of our military
suckers or losers
who does that he knows these
these heroes are somebody's children
somebody's spouse somebody's dad or mom
he understands that and he's going to
restore
our standing in the world because he
knows that america's true strength
comes from setting an example that the
world wants to follow
a nation that stands with democracy not
dictators
a nation that can mobilize and inspire
others
to overcome threats like climate change
and terrorism and
poverty and disease and
with joe and kamala at the helm you're
not gonna have to think about
the crazy things they said every day
yeah but it'll be boring
and that's worth a lot which we want
you're not going to have to argue about
them every day
it just won't be so exhausting yeah you
might be able to have a thanksgiving
dinner without having an
argument you'll be able to
go about your lives knowing that the
president is not going to retweet
conspiracy theories
about secret cabals running the world or
or that
navy seals didn't actually kill bin
laden
think about that the president the
united states retweeted that
imagine what
what
we're not going to have a president that
goes out of his way to insult anybody
who doesn't support him we're not or or
threaten them with jail
that's not normal presidential behavior
we wouldn't tolerate it from a high
school principal
we wouldn't tolerate it from a coach we
wouldn't
tolerate it from a co-worker
we we wouldn't tolerate it in our own
family except for maybe crazy
uncle somewhere you know yeah he's he's
you put him at the kids table though why
would we expect
and ex accept this from the president of
the united states
and how why are folks making excuses for
that oh
well that's just that's just him no it's
no there are consequences
to these actions they embolden other
people
to be cruel and divisive
is trump triggered yet on twitter and
racist
it frays the fabric of our society not
yet
and it affects how our children see
things
and it affects the ways that our
families get along
it affects how the world looks at
america
that behavior matters
character matters
and by the way while he's doing all that
it distracts all of us from the truly
destructive actions
that his appointees are doing
all across the government actions that
affect your lives right
you know the environmental protection
agency that's supposed to protect our
air
and our water is right now run by an
energy lobbyist
that gives polluters free rain to dump
unlimited poison into our air and water
the labor department that's supposed to
protect workers
and their rights right now it's run by a
corporate lobbyist
who's declared war on workers guts
protections
to to keep essential folks safe during a
pandemic
and meanwhile easier for big
corporations to shortchange them on
their wages
the interior department that's supposed
to protect our public lands
and wild spaces our wildlife
and our wilderness and right now that's
run by an
oil lobbyist who's determined to sell
them to the highest bidder
you've got the education department
that's supposed to give every
kid a chance and that's run by a
billionaire who guts rules designed to
protect students from getting ripped off
by for-profit colleges and stiff-arm
students looking for loan relief in the
middle of an economic collapse
i mean the person who runs medicaid
right now
is doing their best to kick people off
of medicaid
instead of sign them up for medicaid
come on
when joe and kamel are in charge they're
not going to surround themselves
with hacks and lobbyists but they're
going to appoint
qualified public servants who actually
care about looking out for you
for your job for your family for your
health
for your security for your planet
[Music]
and that more than anything is what
separates them from their opponents
they actually care about every american
including the ones that don't agree with
them
and they're going to fight for you
every day they care about you
and they care about this democracy
they believe in a democracy the right
to vote is sacred and that we shouldn't
be making people wait in line for 10
hours to cast their ballot
we should be making it easier for
everybody to vote
well no that's not good for trump
they believe that no one especially
the president is above the law
they understand that protest on behalf
of social justice
isn't un-american that's the most
american thing there is
that's how this country was founded
protesting
injustice
they understand we don't threaten our
political opponents
threatening to throw them in jail just
because we disagree with them
they understand that our ability to work
together to solve big problems like a
pandemic
depends more than on just photo ops
it depends on actually learning the
facts
in trump's defense it also depends on
lying and not just
making stuff up whenever it's convenient
we our democracy is not going to work if
the people
who are supposed to be our leaders
lie every day and just
make things up
i mean and we've just become numb to it
we just become immune to it
every single day fact checkers can't
keep
up and and
and look this this notion of
truthfulness and democracy and and
citizenship and
and being responsible
these aren't republican or democratic
principles they're american principles
they're what we're they're what we most
of us grew up
learning from our parents and our
grandparents
they're not white or black or latino or
asian
values their american values human
values
and we need to reclaim them
we have to get those values back
at the center of our public life
and we can but but to do it
we've got to turn out like never before
this is the pivot
we cannot leave any doubt in this
election textbook public speaking
because you know
he the president's already said if this
is even close i'm going to just
make stuff up he's already started to do
it
so we can't have any doubt we can't be
complacent
i don't care about the polls there were
a whole bunch of polls last time
didn't work out because a whole bunch of
folks stayed at home
and got lazy and complacent
not this time not in this election
not this side
listen listen i i understand why
a lot of americans can get frustrated by
government
and can feel like it doesn't make a
difference
even supporters of mine during my eight
years there were times where
stuff we wanted to get done didn't get
done and people said well you know
gosh if obama didn't get it done then
you know maybe it's just not
going to happen look government
is not going to solve every problem it's
true
every elected official is going to make
some mistakes
this is a big complicated country this
isn't narcissistic enough guys
what happened to only i can solve this
doesn't happen overnight
and and believe me i've got first-hand
experience
with the way republicans in congress
abuse the rules to make it
easy for special interests to stop
progress
but we can make things better and we sh
we sure shouldn't be making things worse
a president by himself can't solve every
challenge
in a global economy but if we've got joe
biden and kamala harris in the white
house
and a house and senate that are focused
on working people
it can make a difference and get
millions of people the help they need
a president by himself can't eliminate
all racial bias
in our criminal justice system we
shouldn't create more district attorneys
and states attorneys and sheriffs
and police chiefs focused on equality
and justice it can make things
better
in pennsylvania you just got to flip
nine seats in your state house
just five seats in your state senate to
give democrats control
and new life for policies they'll make a
real difference to working families
right now
it can make things better
and and it in the end pennsylvania
that's what voting is about
making things better not making things
perfect
but putting us on track so that a
generation from now we can look back and
say
things got better starting now and
that's what voting's about
voting is about using the power we have
and
pooling it together to get a government
that's more concerned
and more responsive and more focused on
you
and your lives and your children
and your grandchildren and future
generations
and the fact that we don't get 100 of
what we want right away is not a good
reason
not to vote it means we've got to vote
and then get some change and then vote
some more
and then get some more change and then
keep on voting
until we get it right
and we will never come close
to seeing what it would be like if
everybody voted when i hear people say
well i don't know
your vote don't make a difference we
don't know because
usually no more than half the people who
could be voting vote
55 last election 50 55 of people voting
and then people say oh look you know not
enough change happened well
imagine what would happen if 60 voted
what about 70
imagine january 20th when we swear
in a president and a vice president
who have a plan to get us out of this
mess
who believe in science and have a plan
to protect this planet for our kids
and who care about working americans and
have a plan
to help you start getting ahead and who
believe in racial equality
and gender equality and and believe in
not discriminating against people
because
of their sexual orientation and are
willing
to bring us closer to an america where
no matter what we look like and where we
come from and
who we love and what our last name is if
we go out there and we work we can make
it
and we're part of an american family all
of that is possible
all of that is within our reach if we
vote
big if because let me tell you something
pennsylvania some
people ask me sometimes they say man how
have you been able to take
these last four years just watching all
this
how do you how do you keep your spirits
up
and and i tell them i say look for all
the times these last four years that
we've seen
our worst impulses revealed we've also
seen
what our country can be at its best
we've seen folks of every age and
background
who've packed city centers and airports
in town squares just so families
wouldn't be separated
so another classroom wouldn't get shot
up
so our kids wouldn't grow up on an
uninhabitable planet
we've seen americans of all races
joining together to declare
in the face of injustice that black
lives matter
no more but no less so that no child in
this country feels
the continuing sting of racism
we've seen folks
are our our essential workers
our health care workers risking their
lives day in day out to save
somebody else's loved ones we've seen
people volunteer and contribute
to help those who are having an
especially difficult time that
right now that's true in pennsylvania
that's true all across the country
america is a good and decent place a lot
of trump is
triggered in my chat so much noise
and nonsense that sometimes it's hard
for us to remember
philadelphia i'm asking you to remember
what this country can be what it's like
when we treat each other with respect
and dignity
what it's like when our elected
officials
actually behave responsibly i'm asking
you to believe
in joe's ability in kamala's ability
to lead this country out of these dark
times
and help us build it back better because
we can't
abandon those who are hurting right now
we can't abandon
the children who aren't getting the
education they need right now we can't
abandon
those protesters who inspired us we've
got to channel their activism into
action
we can't just imagine a better future
we've got to fight for it we've got to
out hustle the other side
we've got to work the other side we've
got to vote
like never before and leave no doubt
so make a plan right now for how you're
going to get
involved and vote do it as early as you
can
tell your family tell your friends how
they can vote don't stop with joe and
kamala
make sure you vote all the way down the
ticket
and if we pour all our efforts into
these 13 days
if we vote up and down the ticket like
never before
then we will not only elect joe biden
and kamala harris we will also leave no
doubt about what this country that we
love stands for
we will not leave any doubt about who we
are as a people and the values and
ideals that we embrace
what lincoln called the better angels of
our nature
those are still in us we see him
operating
every single day we see him in
neighborhoods we see him in
churches and synagogues and mosques and
temples
we see him in people helping out a
neighbor
we see him inside our own families we
see
that what is best in us is still there
but we've got to give it voice
and we've got to do it now so let's get
to work people
let's bring this home i love you
philadelphia honk if you're fired up
honk if you're ready to go are you fired
up
are you ready to go are you fired up
are you ready to go
let's go make it up and i love you
philadelphia
thank you i love you
so former president barack obama um
leaving no trumpist untriggered
apparently by saying
really very uncontroversial things and
speaking like a normal person an adult
who knows how to
uh sort of speak i mean it's it's you
know
it was a good speech but we have become
so unaccustomed to it that it
seems you know earth-shattering in some
sense
very small thing that i do take issue
with barack obama using the term we
believe
in science we believe science i think
it's better to say we accept
because one of the things that you know
often you hear from
uh religious folks about how they
they just believe and a lot of these
religious
ideas if no one believes them they
disappear they only
depend on belief science is science
right
mechanics mechanical physics wave theory
germ theory these things exist whether
you believe in them or not or not it's a
question of do you
accept it as a political decision so i
like
accept science rather than believe
science this is a relatively
uh you know small small thing but a very
very interesting speech
as we await donald trump's arrival in
gastonia north carolina which will
certainly certainly certainly be a
completely different type of event
but uh very very interesting okay if
you're leaving you don't you don't have
to leave in fact i would prefer that you
stay
we are going directly into a trump rally
at the top of the hour i'll just do a
little bit of it and then i'm gonna
i have other things to do and we we kind
of know what to expect at these but
we're at least gonna see a little bit
assuming trump's not too late
um if you are leaving though i'm
streaming the debate tomorrow night so
make sure to subscribe if you're
watching on youtube
follow if you're watching on twitch or
like if you're watching on facebook then
tomorrow when i go live
you'll be notified but i would prefer
that you stay
just to uh ju just to just to get that
up there
um i want to get caught up on new member
thank yous people were flooding my
website while president obama was
speaking so let give me 30 seconds to
get caught up and then we'll get beyond
that
christopher strom is new member number
six today
tara bautista is new member number seven
uh eric wine is new member number eight
rhonda leonard is new member number nine
sarah dudka is new member number 10
scott marks is number 11.
and i believe that gets us caught up i i
would love it if you grabbed a
membership on my website joinpakman.com
it's really cheap it takes under a
minute you get extra content made just
for you
and it's our number one funding source
so the streams the podcast the youtube
channel the twit you know all this
different stuff
uh salaries connectivity health
insurance
all of this stuff our primary source of
funding
is uh memberships which you can get at
joinpakman.com
and if you would like take a 66 discount
using that coupon code
2020 now i am glad for you to save
66 and uh yes tomorrow evening
i will be starting about uh 45 30 45
minutes before
the start of the debate also remember we
have our brand new shiny
discord the official david pakman show
discord
at davidpakman.com discord d-i-s-c-o-r-d
we'd love for you to join we've got a
lot of great things going on there
we have a we have memes we have you know
all sorts of different things going on
there so grab that
it's still very small only about 2500
people
um and for people wondering about the
schedule for tomorrow night
it is uh 9 p.m eastern is when
the debate starts i will probably go
live um about 30 40 30 45 minutes before
is my plan as of right now so a lot of
different things
taking place okay
let me do some twitch thank yous and
then i'm going to get to super chats
thanks to
big bad greg for signing up with prime
or no not with prime
just signing up walk hannibal
bearded austrian snuggles
uh oh nicole sandler show i haven't
spoken to nicole for so
so long nicole raided 34 minutes ago
with a party of 10.
i'm sorry i missed that nicole but i do
appreciate it i hope you're doing well
that's me subscribing with prime
destructive breezy of course
and uh broon breed who said hype train
all aboard
and i think that catches me up um
oh no bozo jabroni bozo jabroni has also
subscribed with prime on twitch
which i very much appreciate it uh if
you're just joining us we just finished
watching a barack obama event in
philadelphia
the sun setting on philadelphia and we
are
standing by for donald trump down
in gastonia north carolina
let's take a look at trump's twitter
and see how he's doing from the
standpoint of schedule
so let's see 38 minutes ago
there was video of trump taking off i'm
guessing the video was posted
at least five minutes after he left so
let's say trump
left 45 minutes ago the flight is
scheduled for
um
an hour 15 but then it's a 25-minute
ride
to this place wow so actually if trump
left at 550
that means he's running about 45 minutes
behind potentially so we may not even
get to see any of it as i said i i was
only planning on doing about 15 minutes
of the trump
um event but we're gonna keep an eye on
it and uh we'll we'll do the best we can
to bring you coverage of everything
that is going on okay let me get to
super chats i i'm not going to be able
to go back and read every super chat i
know that they were coming in during the
event i simply it's just not practical
to go back now
but i do appreciate every single one um
let's look at a couple of different
uh a couple of different questions here
nina says what is this we shenanigans
that i don't i don't understand nina i'm
sorry
kurt says i miss president obama but
will be calm and happy if vice president
biden wins
vote for the human race thanks for all
your good work mr pakman greetings west
coast
norway greetings plexus says i'm just
saying
you yanks are easily brainwashed be
highly skeptical of everything any
politician or corporate says
corporatist says even the great obama
yeah this was you know what when during
the democratic primary i mean listen
through the entire the trumpists are
occult they're cult-like and check out
my interview with stephen hassan
if you want to learn more about that but
during the dem primary there was some
cultish behavior
around tulsi there was some cultish
behavior
around a bernie there was cultish
behavior
around marianne williamson she actually
has some
like legit sort of woo-woo cult-like
stuff in her background but
i have said for a very long time um
don't defy any politician
no politician is perfect uh uh any any
politician that gets elected
at the highest level based on the system
that we oh
andrew yang a lot of cult-like behavior
around yang anybody
who gets elected with the system we have
is going to be to some degree beholden
to that system
and they're going to do things that any
sort of clear thinking
uh progressive would disagree with to
some degree
and let's figure out what our choices
are there are lots of things
uh in our lives that are more affected
by state government by municipal local
government
um period let's just let's just put it
there and i agree do not deify
any elected official sarah says thank
you david for making me laugh almost
every day especially during these dark
times thank you i appreciate that
pat says giuliani was looking for his
october surprise yeah if you have not
heard of rudy giuliani
has been caught with his hand and not in
the cookie jar but in his pants
this is from drudge earlier today the
borat 2 movie by sasha baron cohen
coming out on friday and apparently rudy
is in a very
very awkward situation in that film rudy
giuliani has
published he's basically doubling down
saying the borat video is a complete
fabrication i was tucking in my shirt
after taking off the recording equipment
at no time before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate
if sasha baron cohen implies otherwise
he's a stone cold liar
so i'm very much looking forward to
seeing that video uh
when indeed it comes out on friday
that's going to be very
very interesting let me say thank you
to andrew lacansov who's new member
number 12 today
veronica spencer is new member number 13
at joinedpakman.com
alan gardner is number 14.
um lenecki tion
is number 15 and rachel blake
is new member number 16 at
joinpackman.com
i uh i do have a news you know i had
been waiting
until um
the debate to debut joe woodward's
latest masterpiece i'm just going to
dave
i debuted it earlier and i'm going to
play it for you now i played it during
the intro this
is a really great song you guys asked
for
joe woodward to do a song that
incorporates my interviews with jesse
lee peterson
and within like four or five days joe
delivered
so let's take a listen to the latest
song this is called david pakman
is a beta male including samples from my
various appearances with jessie lee
peterson
take a listen to this it's really really
good
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a baby
he is a baby right
david patman he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot hang on agree
with everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male dog
this is a great track it doesn't because
he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
all right let's skip ahead a little bit
i really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're acting
like a because you're asking
bizarre questions and you're wasting my
time
i'm appreciating that i'm coming all
right thank you for coming goodbye
[Music]
goodbye
all men
all right so for people asking where to
find those tracks if you go to
google.com
or google.ca depending on where you live
you type in joseph woodward
soundcloud and unless something very
weird is going on
algorithmically with your prior searches
it should be the number one result
really funny comment i i spotted in the
twitch chat which is i can't tell if
david's show is uh
a satire or not i can't either that's
the that's the funny thing i'm not even
sure whether this show is satire
which is which is i should figure that
out let me put it that way
jonathan sends a super chat uh donna
williams says do you think trump will
ever will try to overshout biden despite
his mic being muted
it's possible yeah i don't i mean
trump's trump's liable to do anything
during tomorrow night's debate eli gray
says clearly we're all blamed
brainwashed plexus yanks lol
brian says hi david big fan iowa auditor
just found that governor reynolds
misused 21 million dollars of cares act
pandemic response fund on a new computer
system
for her building i have not heard that
but i'm going to look into that that's
funny
and tragic if true leon
says tomorrow's debate is going to be
fun as trump shouting while muted yeah i
think it's possible trump will try to do
that
j.r extreme wants to see trump dance to
david pakman or patman
is a uh is a beta male i would like to
see it as well why not
why not tomorrow's debate okay a lot of
questions about tomorrow's debate
tomorrow's debate
is at 9 00 pm eastern 6 p.m pacific
okay i will start my stream
somewhere between 30 and 45 minutes
before the debate starts
all right so keep an eye out for
that tomorrow um just to refresh because
we are
so barack obama already did his thing
earlier
we are now waiting for donald trump in
north carolina
and as i mentioned i was not planning on
covering all
or even much of trump's rally i was
hoping to see the landing in the first
few minutes
if trump is running as late as he may be
running we may we may not see any of it
we will see
but um just a few memes that i put up
earlier one is a jesse lee peterson meme
this is called
jesse we peterson jesse we peterson
um me holding baby jessie lee peterson
we also had this meme jesse lee
ben carson peterson ii
uh with me wearing my very strong data
mail shirt
and cheersing with a beer i do think
this one is better
if you have memes to submit and i'm
gonna be totally upfront with you guys
our new um our new discord has a
sub discord called memes
and people are posting all sorts of
great memes in there but i will tell you
the meme we don't really just do random
memes on the show we do
all uh a sort of like david pakman show
or patman show related stuff so if you
want a shot at it getting on a stream it
should somehow relate to the show and
interview from the show or you know it
should somehow be show related
since we tend not to do just random
random memes
but davidpakman.com discord is the place
for that
if you prefer reddit you can go to
davidpakman.com
reddit whichever you prefer whichever
you prefer it's up to you
other super chats haukey lagging
says why is biden willing to debate the
donald
while his opponent demands biden's
arrest
from the attorney general why does he
not demand to publicly retract that
because trump would never retract it and
if biden just said i'm not debating
because he said i should be in prison
um it i think it ends up making biden
look worse
it will just be framed as biden's afraid
i uh
unfortunately that's the insane reality
of this country right now
zack wilson says patriots are two and
three and third in the division how does
it feel beta male
haven't watched a single game don't
don't even you could tell me the
patriots are 5-0
you could tell me the patriots are 10-0
i wouldn't even know if there had been
10 games or not i have not seen a minute
of sports
since the pandemic started um
we've got bigger fish to fry so to speak
karma says memberships are different
from your website and youtube also can
you repeat your discord okay so a lot of
questions here
website member what's above my head
members and patrons
that's two things that's a combination
of two things it's join pacman.com
memberships
and patreon or patreon pledges
okay um youtube is its own thing
super chats are their own thing on
youtube and uh hold on a second guys
uh we've got some crazy stuff going on
in the uh
uh hold on a second just a lot of
craziness okay
youtube is its own thing super chats are
their own thing now hey people are
saying bitcoin
has exploded today is that true
oh my god bitcoin went to 13 000. can
anybody tell me why bitcoin exploded
i've got to look at my coinbase
what happened with bitcoin today does
anybody know
that's bonkers because of paypal what
happened with paypal
i didn't see what happened with paypal
paypal oh paypal added cup oh that's
right no i did see that
now paypal that is actually huge
that is massive wow wow
uh i'm glad that
well geez glad i bought in in that march
dip that's crazy
paypal is a bitcoin okay yeah i got it
paypal says venmo will have a bitcoin
wallet oh my god
it's crazy what's going on okay very
good uh stephen parmese says nevada is a
state that has been deeply affected by
the pandemic
here's a link to the lvcva website which
covers numbers for vegas
all right i'm not going to click that on
stream right now but i will take a look
at it
prior guy says when the constitution was
written life expectancy was about 38
years if they had known people would
live so long do you think they would
have limited
the terms of the supreme court justices
you know that's actually deceptive
because
a lot of the reason that um a lot of the
reason that
life expectancy was that low is because
of infant mortality
so at birth the average was 38 but
that's
very very deceptive the truth is that
many people were living into their 70s
and 80s at that time
a lot of people don't understand this
read angus deaton's work
read hans rosling's work there's a lot
of people who have written about this
i'm not arguing with you about your your
take away necessarily but
understand that if you looked then at
life expectancy at age five
the numbers are far closer to where they
are today just something to understand
okay
um uh very good all right
lily lawless says hi david it's me
leneka tuwen love how you pronounce my
name but i'm sticking with lily lawless
on here your dutch is getting better
yeah i really struggle with
finnish and dutch names it's and we have
a lot of members
from finland norway sweden denmark
uh netherlands and uh
i do the best i can i do the best i can
democratic brotherhood says british dude
here
if d trump loses that will have a major
effect on uk
politics it will signal the end of
brexit populism which ran alongside
trump that's an interesting take from
the uk that's very interesting
this crowd seems particularly corona
ridden
or you know at risk of spreading
coronavirus
um people are like extra close together
it's
weird very weird thank you to deborah
mcdonald
1958 with the twitch prime
sub i love it ethelyrion
electric head says obama's a brush of
fresh air
epithermal thanking for the coverage
emma
black white rook has subscribed for 11
months
zigzig hipf the phony pope
rookie breezy all right
that's enough of those mispronunciations
let's move on
to some others um
okay bdecamps
paid me twenty dollars to say trump2020.
listen every trumpist watching on
youtube
you should really try to lobby my
audience and spending 20 bucks to say
trump 2020
i think is a really good investment of
your of your money
so to the trumpists watching right now
each of you
please pay 20 dollars to say trump 2020.
i think that's a really great way to get
the vote out
jay warden says hey david did you see
the proud boys
threatening emails it's happening in my
home country county
and i'm so upset and ready to throw
hands i did see it it's insane uh
and i'm gonna look at more of it for
tomorrow's show
shambly game says love your show david
not gonna lie i feel a bit uneasy about
this election how
confident are you in biden winning this
election so here's here's my take
i'm not a betting man but if you said
david even odds
bet on the winner i would bet biden but
i think there are many scenarios where
trump gets reelected
and we need to do everything we can to
prevent that from happening
sally says hey david do you think chris
wallace will have more control over
trump now that he can mute well
chris wallace isn't the moderator
tomorrow it's kristin welker
from uh nbc jamie says i've been in and
out so i sort of missed it but did you
hear lindsey graham backed out of the
next debate
i did not but after how the fir the last
one went i'm not totally shocked
jamie harrison just obliterated him
obliterated it was brutal
kimitha says david please tell those
voters in the solid red states i live in
oklahoma
that their votes are as important as
blue states and all others yeah we've
got to run up the vote in every state
every single state we need to run up the
score
every vote counts let's get a huge
margin in pen in
california let's reduce the margin in
oklahoma
you guys understand everything there's
no reason not to vote
no reason not not to vote let me say
thank you to breezy and comstock rocker
with 10 and 11 month subs on twitch also
i
i apologize for this brief brief
interjection but i do need to get caught
up on website members so i don't uh
insult people dominic dill schnitter
is new member number 17 today sean
ricketts
is new member number 18. dave marvin
is new member number 19. liz beth
gergich is new member number 20.
michael bildstein is new member number
21
and leslie reyes or as we would say in
argentina
rishis is new member number 22
at joinedpakman.com a
camp's coming back for more what a
masochist sending me
another 20 to say thank you
trump 2020. any trumpists
20 is a beautiful price to get trump
2020 up on my stream
for 15 seconds if you want to do it go
ahead and do it
noogie says i'm friends with a doctor
who supports trump
when i try to send him articles he
replies with memes
a doctor former department head jesus
christ
yeah you know actually
let me do something just because you
guys you guys might find this
interesting
so we had hatred mail today on the david
pakman show
and a question i had for the audience
was
do you like what what profession
whoa what profession do you think this
person has like do you think this person
could be
was that is that like a huge uh that's
some kind of huge insect that was weird
is could this person be an accountant
could this person be a doctor
take a listen to this uh this is by by
the way let me just explain this hold on
what you're about to hear is a
professional voice-over artist
reading an email i got this is not the
voice of the person who emailed me this
is a professional voice over artist okay
take a listen to this
what could their profession be soy boy
cuck boy pacman
fill the seat winning winning
winning trump forever i'd put money up
that pacman is either a cuck
or gay can tell this guy likes to gossip
that's what i think of when i see soft
pale intellectuals who aren't actually
about america or
freedom and a jew to boot
the full package okay
so i see a lot of people saying that
whoever wrote that clearly is unemployed
but especially when i see super chats
like this
a doctor i know is responding with memes
it's less clear to me it's less clear to
me i think that these people exist
i mean listen if you go to tennessee or
louisiana
the state is filled with republican
doctors the state is filled with
republican
therapists and i think this is a reality
that that we just have to understand i
and i think if we if we don't
acknowledge it i think we are uh you
know doing ourselves a disservice we're
not being realistic
okay noah says trump supporters
robots okay um
what else we got here jessie lamoi
i have already started doing a spanish
show
every sunday 4 p.m east 1 p.m west
on the tv channel estrella or as i would
say in argentina
okay 4 p.m east coast 1 pm west coast
it's only on about 45 or 50 cable
systems
a lot of them in california florida
texas etc
so you've got to check your local
listings they are launching an
online platform soon and
once that happens the the spanish show
will be available
uh globally really it'll really be uh
it'll go global
okay dinosaur kale
says obama was the greatest president in
u.s history
unless a larger financial contribution
says
otherwise wow bruness
says biden 2020 so now there seems to be
a 20
battle between pro and anti-trump people
happening
zesty says from the standpoint of
trump's infidelity how do you feel about
people getting
upset about biden looking for republican
folks in in for his cabinet
so here's the deal i actually
interviewed la mayor eric garcetti about
that who's a biden co-chair and i said
listen eric i have to tell you
when i see biden supposedly considering
republicans for his cabinet i get
worried
because i get bipartisanship and all of
that stuff but if we're going to get
things done
i don't think we're getting rid of you
know i don't think we're phasing out
fossil fuel vehicles
if we have a republican secretary of
transportation
and for now my understanding is these
are just rumors
so i don't love it i'm not gonna lie but
um
i do think that there might be some
value to
you know you put some symbolic
republican who's like
the center center center republican
in some relatively inoffensive position
to say hey
i even have people from the other party
in my cabinet
i understand the strategic value of that
uh but i don't want republicans involved
in any serious way
in joe biden's administration that's uh
that's for damn sure
there seems to be kind of like a hub up
going on here i don't even understand
what's happening i guess we're just
still waiting
uh for donald trump or prump
as some people call him to arrive in
north carolina
um let's see todd asks if i've ever
played skyrim
i have not i have not ever ever ever
ever played skyrim
um i want to say thanks to onalu for
subscribing with twitch
blue zack and puny or
poony i don't know exactly
the pronunciation there also a big thank
you to
jax harrington who is new member number
23 today
and david farrar who is new member
number 24
at joinpackman.com we are
standing by for donald trump in gastonia
north carolina earlier barack obama
spoke in philadelphia pennsylvania
um very very a good speech from barack
obama certainly some things we could
disagree with some things that were kind
of hokey
but a very good speech and just
refreshing given what we've seen from uh
from mango
lately bo benson is coming in with a
different idea buckethead 2020.
and yeah that's uh not not a completely
unreasonable thing to say
but uh interesting nonetheless
interesting nonetheless
um there is a lot of action i i get the
sense that something is like sort of
wrong at the rally i don't know exactly
what's going on
let's see donald trump's twitter and see
if anything else has been posted about
his landing
uh donald trump now posting video of him
leaving
north uh leaving dc an hour ago already
and unclear exactly where donald trump
is right now but maybe not super far
from the rally i don't expect it to
start on time
and i was not planning on covering all
of it so we'll we will we will see where
we get
bde camps now sending a
50 super chat with trump
taxes cut i have more money trump 2020.
how insane is it that the top
contributor today who sent me 90
is apparently an unhinged trump
supporter does that make anybody sad
or does it make people happy you guys
tell me
sad or happy seems like a waste of money
but
anybody have a strong opinion on that
people don't really know people are
happy okay
happy people okay good uh alejandro says
congratulations on your spanish show
david
papason all right
alejandro's parents are fans and he's
gonna let them know about the spanish
show very soon toots sweet
seer media says did you know many
iranians prefer trump to biden
while they are the ones being punished
but think trump is the guy that
understand
iran mullahs i did not know that i do
not have any
i don't have any particular um sense
of where uh the iranian
community or iranian is on trump i know
a few iranian people uh
the two whose politics i know are both
voting for for uh joe biden
that that it's it's a it's a sample size
of two
um okay what else do we have here kelly
says yay i'm excited about your spanish
show what do you think about the
moderator muting trump i'm not in
agreement it may help him look good
no so here's the deal from each
15-minute segment tomorrow night during
the last debate
the muting only is for four minutes it's
during when so
when biden gets two minutes trump's
muted when trump gets to meet at
two minutes biden's muted that's four
minutes the other 11 minutes of each
segment there's no muting so i think it
could actually be the perfect way
for trump to look bad by shouting over
the muting
and for trump to look bad by continuing
to interrupt during the other 11 minutes
so i don't think it's going to
i don't think it's going to help trump i
don't think it will
waller is me is coming in
out of nowhere coming in hot with a 50
super chat says i've been busy teaching
missed a lot of your live youtube
offerings
this is to make up for missed donations
oh my goodness you don't have to do that
hopefully people are okay with me
donating more than the trump dude
1.05 million subscribers 2 million here
we go
it's going to be a while till 2 million
it's going to be a while
christopher asked why is trump always so
late how
delightful was it that obama started
five minutes early today
isn't that just the best uh it's it's
just
it's it's emblematic it's a microcosm
of everything that's wrong with this
administration it's really something
else
uh kenny says regardless of what
conspiracy theories and october
surprises come up there's a total lack
of critical thinking amongst everyone on
both sides
there is a lack of critical thinking in
the united states as an educational
problem but i disagree with you that
we're seeing the same phenomena on both
sides
uh if you go to if you talk to
sort of uninformed leftists you don't
see the same
type of ignorance that you see
when you go to a trump rally and
interview people so i think that we
don't want to both
sides ourselves into into uh idiocy
i think that's a bad idea uh what else
do we have here
vasil vanda says did pensin giuliani
test negative for
covid i don't know i don't know maybe
that's what giuliani should go with that
he thought he was uh he thought that
the swab for for um
that the swab process for covid was
different than what some people thought
and that that's what was happening in
this picture
is that maybe maybe an explanation let's
look at what's on drudge report right
now i want to see what the headline is
so let's see it's still that oh my god
still that is the headline on drudge
report by the way if you're just showing
up and you have no idea what's been
going
on today you need to google rudy
giuliani borat right now
let's see what the other headlines are
uh
trump's secret bank account drudge has
almost gone anti-trump it's pretty funny
texas tied iowa leaning blue georgia
slipping
mitt picks another yeah mitt romney did
not vote for for prompt
interestingly enough uh okay
very good excellent everything happening
everything happening very strongly
other super chats hugh hundos has just
ordered who rules the world by noam
chomsky have you read it
thanks for the relevant content i have
not read it
uh i want to get this right chain
chimale
says do you think the senate still
serves a good purpose population-wise it
doesn't represent our population like
the house so the power at wield seems
oddly large love your attitude
the senate is a completely undemocratic
force
california has about 50 60 times the
population of wyoming and yet they have
the same representation in the senate
it is fundamentally undemocratic and it
is one of the four or five systems that
i outlined earlier this week
show us uh the total lack of
balance in favor of republicans
electoral colleges balanced in favor of
republicans
gerrymandering in favor of republicans
and on and on
and on uh i want to say thanks to robert
michael joseph who is new member number
25 today at joinedpakman.com
let's do something let's go for 50. i
would love it
i would really love it and so appreciate
it if you
listen if you have a couple bucks and
and don't hate me
uh go to joinpakman.com and grab
yourself a membership it's the number
one funding source for the program for
the streams for the entire thing
we're looking to fill the bar up with
blue
and uh you can use the coupon code 2020
now
to save 66 percent
it looks like there's a bit of a hubbub
we may see donald trump soon i was
expecting him to be much much later
as i mentioned i will not be covering
all of this probably 10 or 15 minutes
we've been
doing the obama coverage we've got a
long day tomorrow with the with the
debate but i wanted to do just a little
bit
thanks to liz tabulus for the pledge
on patreon liz is supporter number 26
today as we prepare to maybe
maybe see donald trump arrive here
photographers and
others getting themselves in a tizzy
seemingly um
but we will we will see what happens
what else do we have here um
other super chats
chakaseki says as a radiologist i'm
embarrassed about physicians is that
true chakaseki you're a radiologist
that's very interesting
that is interesting so is it anti-social
is that
is radiology good for anti-social people
as a radiologist i'm embarrassed about
physicians who support trump who allowed
kovid to ravage our nation a violation
of our hippocratic oath very interesting
i would not have guessed chaku
from your super chats that that you were
uh you were a physician that's
interesting
sierra asking if i've seen totally under
control on hulu
i have not but it sounds interesting
dark cricket says where is rogan on the
political spectrum
oh there's mark meadows what a
disgusting human being um
i believe joe rogan is
socially liberal economically
center-left
and culturally conservative he's part of
a lot of
cultural elements that tend to lean
right
and i think that's where sometimes the
the sort of uh
you know mixed up politics come from
mark meadows thumbs-upping and with no
mask and just a disgusting disgusting
person
i don't know why this videographer is
not wearing a mask it's it's just
it's it's vile guys it's really really
vile
alexis says trump left his roids in
adderall at the white house so he made
them turn around the plane to go get him
look at this mania that's going on here
in anticipation of donald trump
brad says trump is late because he has
to figure out his messaging he has no
message he's all defense
he just does the same stump speech every
day
same tired attacks every single day
janelle says can you explain the hunter
emails i i have a clip about that
uh a couple clips on my youtube channel
um please have jessie lee peterson back
on
i'm very much on sex amazing
ben rowling says david do you think if
dems control
get control there will be discussion of
campaign finance reform or shifting to a
ranked choice
voting platform quite frankly no
i hate to be real with you guys but i
don't think those are
high priorities for the democratic party
right now
bean says is the borat movie the
unexpected surprise for the democrats
that that would be funny um just as a
reminder guys google rudy giuliani borat
very very incredible things going on
uh wow wow wow is the only thing i can
say about it
really crazy stuff five minutes says
where did all the stolen ppe go
did 18 year old ice give illegal
hysterectomies where's bar wolf and
their gestapo
i've covered all of those topics on the
youtube channel
puneo says hey why do the popular vote
results matter so much to you
isn't it only electoral college the
reason it matters is
the more lopsided the popular vote is in
favor of joe biden
the more political pressure it will put
on a court if a court gets involved
not to not to um
rule in trump's favor we're just going
to mute
i'm sorry we have to drop a few ban
hammers you know it's crazy i was
i was um watching the great
levy rosman's stream on twitch the other
day great chess streamer
along with so many others hikaru and
anna rudolph
and alex botez and eric rosen you know
you guys know you know there's all these
different chess streamers
and um we were talking about banning
people and he said
he's only ever had like 10 people banned
in a single stream and his streams are
really long
we've had streams where like a hundred
people have gotten the band hammer
it's it's crazy it's crazy the toxicity
and uh we'll just keep banning people
you know it's it's really no sweat
i'm not losing sleep over it
uh sean says how do people not become
heavy drinkers after watching so many of
trump's
rallies very fair question very very
fair question
karsten says if you live in a democratic
country go voting
i saw somebody on twitch just asked
whether i already voted i did
i did and in fact i posted a video of it
and you can see it on my instagram at
david.pacman i'm david.pakman on
instagram
and there is video legal video
of me voting aussie says as a
californian i got tired of rogan
complaining about it
about california i see candace
says gastonia is the perfect place for
mr magoo mango since it is the butt of
all jokes in my
the charlotte area okay four more secret
service guys have come out
so clearly it is time for mango
a donald trump arriving and uh being
followed around
secret service seems more jumpy than
usual here maybe it's because of the
proximity of the crowd
i don't know let's see what music we've
got just as a reminder i'll be here for
about 10 minutes of this
continuing the ruse that donald trump
likes country music
i want to say thanks to patricio
gonzalez
who is new member number 27 today jared
kulp
is new member number 28 which i
appreciate
martin knew when wheeze i am sure i got
that wrong is new member number 29
adam pettway is new member number 30.
valerie king
is 31 and blake west is new member
number 32. love it guys i i really do
appreciate that
uh as we wait for donald trump here
um heavy heavy heavy
corona spread and masks
already down what's the point of the
mask if it's down while you're crowded
together
i really don't get it i really don't get
it
dear god what a sycophantic fiasco truly
truly a sycophantic fiasco going on here
um posting from new zealand
feels like trump is constantly late
because he's waiting for his decks to
kick in
so he doesn't look and sound like a
sickly loser for his fans
um if you want interesting uses of decks
uh read the book into thin air by the
great john krakauer dexamethasone
figures bigly into tragedies that have
taken place
uh on mount everest um all right
let's listen to what's going on let's
take it let's take it all in
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
it's almost satirical it's almost a
satirical song
[Music]
there's something special in the air
tonight here folks
could be corvids
[Applause]
well i want to thank everybody thank you
gastonia
gastonia
[Applause]
sounds like a medical condition 13 days
can you believe it
[Applause]
13 days from now and you see what's
going on you see
oh my god he's high as a kite a little
nervous over there you know
the deep state the democrat the deep
state all of these people that we've
been dealing with they're getting a
little bit nervous aren't they huh
he's got to be on something
[Music]
we're going to win this state 13 days
this great great state
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
let's hope not
with your vote we will continue to cut
taxes
cut regulations lower drug prices like
never before support
our great police and law enforcement how
is he so sweaty already
[Applause]
protect your incredible second
amendment 74 degrees there
defend our borders maintain energy
independence
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped
with the phrase made in the usa
imagine falling for this i know that
it's happening
now we will deliver record prosperity
epic job growth a very safe vaccine
that's coming very quickly
the crowd unsure whether to cheer for a
vaccine
they hate it when i say it you know you
turn onto this
msdnc and fake new cnn all you hear is
kovind
kovetkov and kovakovic right well
230 000 people have died that's all they
put on because they want to scare the
hell out of everyone
and you know the more testing you have
the more cases they say cases are up
yeah testing is up we have more testing
than
india china and almost every other
country put together
you could say it's ridiculous at the
same time we did a good job but it shows
a lot of cases
and yes thank you he's a great job we
did do a great job
normal life will fully resume and next
year
will be the greatest economic year
in the history of our country that's
where we're at
this election is a choice between a
trump
super recovery or a biden steep
depression and that's what you're going
to have obviously
it's between a trump boom or a biden
lockdown he wants to lock you down you
know
by the way biden's expressed nothing
about
wanting to lock down the country
here it is open actually
open up your state governor it's time
you've been long enough
watch november 4th north carolina we're
opening up
november 4th you know they're only doing
this for political reasons many many
states big big
powerful states they're open they're
doing great some of the major states
your governor doesn't want to
and you look at michigan michigan we won
in the supreme court
she had no constitutional right to do
what she did
the only one that had freedom in
michigan was her husband he had plenty
of freedom
he went swimming and he went voting
blacks for trump cops for
trump lady is fired upon the vaccine
the pandemic close your schools and shut
down
our country and that's what he'll do he
will massively raise your taxes he won't
even know he's doing it by the way but
let's go into it
he has no clue but that's all right
you in regulations dismantle your police
departments dissolve our borders
confiscate your guns that would be
happening very quickly
wouldn't happen probably would see
record gun sales scare 180 million
people private healthcare they love it
they want to eliminate it
they want to go to socialized medicine
socialized
you too can go to a hospital ward and
see how your cold is coming along wait
for four or five days before you get in
terminate
release liberty destroy the suburbs and
slash defenseman bad person
devastating north carolina's incredible
military families by the way
we've invested more in the military in
the last three years than at any time
in our nation's history all made in the
usa
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain in
exchange for his party's nomination
which he should have never gotten
if pocahontas got out two days earlier
casual xenophobia what she did to crazy
bernie was unbelievable
because they split up the crazy vote
and that vote doesn't like kim verma i
don't know you know they're not doing so
well
you know people like aren't showing up i
shouldn't say this is too early right
oh there they are 61
from north carolina some of the great
women of the world
61 times oh oh look at you
and you have your husbands with you
tonight look at you
look at you good good
now i asked them last time how many
times have you gone
61 gone where thank you thank you
i love you too
all right so don't explain thank you
that's so nice trump's collapsing so
badly
there might be a black hole before we
know it and you know what one of these
fake anchors said
donald trump started crying during his
speech
not that that's a bad thing in fact it
would probably good maybe it would be
good if i did you know some people say
hey why did you do that every once in a
while having some sense that trump
experiences emotions
would probably help him make fake people
i joke and i say
women of the suburbs please please love
me i've done so good
wow i've done so good
i've done so good for you please just
like this you're only kidding i mean i'm
being suck
please but i mean it because i'm saving
your suburbs i'm going to stop
low income housing i'm going to stop
projects
he's going to stop all of it so i mean
but i said
i said jokingly the last time out
last time out i said women of the
suburbs please
please love me i've done such a good job
please
no and on 60 minutes
take 60 minutes she said you are begging
for women to love you
you said women please love you
that's true you'll see where did you see
we have a little
surprise for 60 minutes
that should be interesting no
no it's true i won't name the anchor do
you know the anchor
huh
so no she said uh
well you you were begging for women to
love you i said no no
that was sarcastic that was remember i
said russia russia russia if you're
listening
please give us whatever it was hillary's
emails or whatever
and then everybody laughed and i left
but they kept me whatever it was
and they said he's kind of like the main
issue he made in the campaign
shifty shift and all that group they are
sick
so you see from now on when i say women
of the suburbs please love me i'm gonna
have to say i'm only kidding i'm only
kidding because otherwise
but they'll take that out too sleepy joe
biden has handed control of his party
over to socialist communist
marxists and left the south
[Music]
and they're filled with hatred venom and
rage
the first thing washington democrats
will do
if sleepy joe is elected is go to sleep
i guess
[Applause]
you know i had a leader that called me a
really dynamic leader called me up about
two weeks ago said
i don't want to deal with him he's
always going to be sleeping can you
imagine that
the word gets around but the first thing
washington democrats will do if biden
gets elected
is pack the supreme court with radical
left judges
really i doubt biden will do it your
second amendment and many other things
i don't think biden's for that look at
the things they have to rule on they
will pack it
somebody said 16 i said why not 18 why
not twenty one at twenty-two
and he's gotta also tell us who the
judges are he won't tell he won't talk
because if he does
he's gonna totally lose the radical left
so he won't say
he's in his basement you're right about
that
no i go through these interviews every
question is a total kill
right every question they're going for
the kill and this guy walks out holding
ice cream
and the press is out there the fake news
and this guy
what kind of ice cream are you eating uh
ah chocolate i think in vanilla too
i say why don't they ever ask me those
questions right they don't ask me all
right guys i think that we've had
this is literally the same speech every
night so we've got a really long one
tomorrow with the debate i look forward
to seeing you guys 8 15 8 30 p.m eastern
time tomorrow night for the final
presidential debate
um the fbi is scheduled to make an
announcement about election security
this actually could be pretty big this
is happening in a few
minutes i will not be covering it but i
will be following it we will discuss
tomorrow thanks for joining me for
barack obama's
rally thanks for joining me for a little
bit of donald trump's we'll see
everybody tomorrow
you